amazing swell hey that's actually pretty
whoa
that was more lethal than I imagined it
would be who need to put spikes on it oh
so sorry guy not sorry at all little
kiddos sorry for missing you try this
again Shepard oh I can click weapons on
our people I don't know okay thank you
can I get a robot that's not a row it is
rule it is a robot just watch nut you
with my Jan axe don't worry about it's
alright it's okay they were kidding
about when they said that this one was
awesome holy crap
you missed you had every opportunity
hitting your hands and you missed it was
right there in front of you what were
you thinking cannon Oh got me two Flying
Swords well oh yeah
flags words - wow so perfectly timed
well the humanity it's okay spike set
cannon spirit guide robot ten swords
Seven Swords pistol everything a man
could hope for in his quest to destroy
be on ball Ultra
japanese my heroes oh that seems to be a
common theme episode i mean sexy my sexy
husband sorry i keep messing with my
hair it's not cooperating today i can't
wash it yet cuz the dye has to sit in
the hair for a while you guys don't care
about this at all but this is my
personal problems and where else am I
gonna fit my personal problems sorry son
I didn't want to kill you why would a
responsible dad such as myself everyone
who murder lies his son I just wanted to
make sure that you were safe in the
playpen broke that with my spine yeah my
spines been carbon reinforced how about
my face [ __ ] that didn't work at all I
didn't need that arm anyway I just
wanted to rip it and throw it to the
wind face slam well I broke my pelvis in
12 places but this is the next one's
gonna work ah see Boosh iron pelvis with
well you think that's gonna stop me dick
bag yeah I breakdance at the hilarity of
your jokes BAM [ __ ] eat a dick showed
you Oh
winning boxes also spinning boxes I
don't know what these words that are
coming out of my mouth mean though all
the matters is that victory approaches
groin first whoop scuse me sorry I'm not
sorry at all these are all the beer
bottles leftover from my drinking habits
pardon pardon me is anything actually
gonna be a challenge here
no even that's not gonna kill me ride on
table why ain't a game full of vehicles
that are perfectly appropriate for
riding on would I run a ride on the
table welp here we go then you know I I
retract my previous statement this is
actually pretty Fanta oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh
oh yeah table out of control hello wormy
I'm just gonna go down your hole here
never mind
rides over please throw ah well ow fries
one for ya that's gonna get me oh [ __ ]
I'm a winner I'm having a seizure
save your son well the kidnapper take
some of that son I just want to cut your
leg off so he'd be easier to drag away
strands one more time Oh God
I gave him more ammo with which to be
use you [ __ ] you damn it I just pinned
you more firmly to them
I'll never get you back I don't want
more well I just wanted to rub his back
a little bit it looks sore from this
distance well Billy now you don't have
to worry about being kidnapped because
you're dead finally Oh perfect throw and
I saved Billy too even though he's being
sat on by weapons of death and
destruction you go and haunt someone
else psychopath killer Oh damage power
and speed break is the spacebar control
Oh at this point is their fault they're
walking into my spinning foot maybe my
superpower is that my arm is absolutely
uncontrollable miserable my friends oh
god that's horrifying
get away oh I'm starting to see things I
need my medication Oh God perfectly
justified in my actions
headless Santa Jesus okay you just keep
your butt right there
I'll be fine back here in nightmare land
save yourself Wow God I'm eating it I'm
eating it with my brain [ __ ] you
I saved the both of us you [ __ ]
impossible 94% use razor leaf [ __ ] all
the stories good death is right behind
this screen
what's so long as I stay here death is
not death damn it Oh every single one of
those went through my dog yes that was a
trick you just had to make him think
that I was going higher than our wars
the challenge the challenge was to fly
and become a piece of modern art then I
did it greatest I'm a Rocket Man it was
gonna be
building up feed broke my leg so fast
here we go Rocketman shooting off like a
firework cuz baby I'm a firework that's
going easy click cleaver fall I've never
seen a cleaver fall before this doesn't
seem like it's gonna work out well for
me let's try the stealthy path but it's
ok oh my god dude I'm gonna leave but my
heart goes out to you cuz ow are you
gonna say something
jet pack man version to you ok am i from
World War two or something or do I do I
have a Nike branded backpack there's
everything on top of my head I did not
win I want to be very clear bottle run
hard my time and I'm extremely good at
them but I don't know what you're
talking about in terms of this
this was apparently the hardest bike
fall in existence because robbery oh my
gosh James go
impossible poon okay that was a lot of
explosions it's going to be equally as
cool as three consecutive explosions cuz
I hope so oh god wait the death ball
isn't the murder other people this has
been happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye